this is a moment of profound loyalty for
the Armed Forces to declare to the newly
anointed and crowned King
their determination to serve
the Garrison's heart major there
Mr Stokes who's planned all of this will
have given his signal now to the Palace
who are watching
and there you see the ranks of the
senior officers of the Armed Forces at
the front there
followed by the household division
the Royal Navy the senior service of the
Armed Forces and then the regiments
cause
and other units of the British army
followed by the Royal Air Force and then
at the back the Commonwealth
representatives of the Realms and other
countries in the Commonwealth and the
bands from the three armed forces
at the rear
everything is ready what we will see is
these masked
Sailors soldiers and aviators
giving a royal salute
to the king the head of the Armed Forces
followed by three cheers
of forces
reasons
um
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
the prize will replace that dress
replace
China
oh quick balls
[Music]
three cheers and a royal salute for the
king and interestingly in the front of
the Imperial State Crime that he wears
is a red ruby
that was worn by King Henry V at the
Battle of Agincourt
14 15 and it's an extraordinary thought
that here the King has received the
Loyalty of his Armed Forces as he
returns into the palace and probably the
chance to have a bit of a rest
before the balcony appearance and fly
past at half past two
meanwhile the pipes are playing King
Charles III